[MUSIC PLAYING]
ROB DODSON: Hey, folks.
What's up?
Rob, here.
Just wanted to let you know that
next week, November 17 and 18,
we are hosting our
annual Chrome Dev Summit.
And we're streaming the
entire thing live for free.
We've got talks from
Paul Lewis and Paul Irish
on building performant web apps.
Paul Bakaus will give an
update on Chrome Dev tools.
And yours truly will
be there talking
about building progressive
apps with Polymer.
And you can go check out the
whole thing over on the Chrome
Developers YouTube Channel.
We've got a live stream
right here for you to view.
And also, we'll be
posting all the videos
as they become available.
So go there, click the Subscribe
button, tell all your friends,
and I'll see you next week
at the Chrome Dev Summit.